[Music]
big shot gangster putting together crew
you in wait a long time for a shot like
this what are you doing with having the
boy
we need a ship the Millennium Falcon's
every ship isn't for everyone
she needs a particular type of pilot
done flirting
these people not defense
there's a lesson to be learned here
got a really good feeling about this
[Music]
you're after something
[Music]
is it revenge
[Music]
money or is it something else look good
little rough around the edges been good
heard about a job big shot gangster
putting together crew
I'm a driver and I'm a flier
I waited a long time for a shot like
this
what do you think well what do you know
you got a land on a ship yeah no guy
he's the best model around I heard a
story about you I was wondering if it's
true everything you said about me
it's true l-3 let's go with a mean man's
face these guys
if you come with us you're in this life
for good might wanna buckle up baby
[Music]
let me give you some advice but soon
everyone will betray you and you'll
never be disappointed I got a really
good feeling about this
when do you know how to fly a hundred
and ninety years old look great
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]